if we need any further evidence of the
difficulties of being human
we need only study the poignant
phenomenon that psychologists call
dermatillomania more commonly known
as skin picking those who suffer from
this
will by definition be at the anxious end
of the spectrum
few days will be free of great worry
sometimes it'll be a specific concern
with a threat that feels like it will be
the end of us
sometimes it might just be a general
eeriness and nameless dread
in response as we've probably done for
years
we will start to pick perhaps we reach
for one of our hands
and a very special zone we've almost
certainly not told anyone about
a zone of hardened skin made up of extra
layers that we begin to press
or squeeze at file down or unsheathe
or we go to an area of our face and
start to worry away
pinching squeezing lifting skewering
it might equally or also be a part of
our lips we go to
or a bit of our ankle in all cases
the skin buckles damages goes sore
and on occasion when we go too far
starts to bleed
perhaps profusely if someone were to
come into the room
they might gasp though we generally do a
good job of covering up the blood once
we're done
we know of course we shouldn't be doing
any of this
but it feels at the time so nice or
more accurately irresistible like the
only thing that's going to work
like exactly the action that will be
able to deliver relief
what can it matter in the context that
we'll be left with a
pitted face or a bleeding foot or a
purple raw
thumb it's what we had to do and have
been doing probably for many years
we know we do it but it escapes and
resists
direct thought this might be the first
time we've ever heard
anyone else talking about it
dermatillomania the psychologists tell
us
has to do with anxiety that much is
evident
what is distinctive is how the anxiety
is being handled
some will act out their pain in dramatic
and noisy ways
screaming insulting cursing skin picking
is a quieter
more solitary way of trying to come to
terms with alarm and self-loathing
it is predominantly the introverts
disease
the skin picker might well like to
scream panic loudly
tell someone to go away or collapse in
another person's welcoming arms
but their characters have been shaped
through eons of solitude
they have no faith in any possibility of
turning towards someone else for help
they feel fundamentally alone they only
have experience of directing anger and
sorrow
in on themselves they are taking their
pain out
on the only character they can reach
knowing all this helps us to imagine
what a cure might look like
for a start it will involve recognizing
the degree of solitude
that has inspired this kind of masochism
no one ends up picking their skin raw
who had an early consistent experience
of
tenderness and attuned care one does
this kind of thing because
absolutely no one was around or those
that were
did a lot of humiliating it may help to
recognize
that one is still now terrified pretty
much all the time
the targets may shift losing one's job
being made fun
of being sexually rejected ridicule but
the essential drift
is that one is a terror struck person
we tend only to be in a position to
acknowledge our distress
when someone is around who could
understand
when we can compassionately realize that
the picking is about fear and
self-disgust
and the legacy of neglect or cruelty we
are in a better position to start to see
rather than merely be compelled by our
pain
we need to find a better way of being
worried
we're trying to gain control over a
cruel seeming and cold world
but turning our index finger raw or
taking a pen knife to our heel
isn't where the issue lies we need to
know that this isn't some
unanalyzable quirk it's a known
and very moving problem one of the many
things a sensitive mind will do
in response to a lack of love and to a
basic fear
that's had to be born alone we need to
start to pick
at the real source of the agony and
learn to leave our innocent
bleeding body in peace
our emotional first aid kit provides a
set of useful salves to some of life's
most
challenging psychological situations
including friendship love sex work
and self click the link on screen now to
find out more